a priori cette ville ne représente pas
d'intérêt stratégique on est à 700
kilomètres de donetsk à l'est on est à
420 km de kherson au sud on est vraiment
loin des lignes de front c'est en plus
une ville qui est une ville refuge pour
tous les gens qui depuis l'invasion du
24 février ont fui les combats parce que
c'est un noeud un noeud ferroviaire donc
c'est assez pratique surtout pour les
gens qui fuyaient le sud alors c'est
vrai que cette ville accueille les
quartiers généraux de l'armée de l'air
mais encore une fois on est on est loin
des combats apparemment c'est un
bâtiment en particulier qui a été ciblée
qui s'appelle la maison des officiers et
qui appartient à l'armée de l'air mais
ici on nous confirme que même si ça
appartient à l'armée de l'air ce
bâtiment n'est pas du tout utilisé à des
fins militaires c'est plutôt une sorte
de maison culturelle la preuve elles
mêmes avoir un concert qui était prévu
ce week end avec une candidate
ukrainienne au dernier au dernier rang
aux visions enfin une chanteuse qui
voulait devenir la candidate de
l'ukraine pour l'eurovision après voilà
ce que disent les russes 7 cétacés est
assez vague pour l'instant on n'a pas
vraiment de réaction si ce n'est celle
de la rédactrice en chef de russia today
qui dit selon ses propres sources à elle
au sein de l'armée russe que dans ce
bâtiment au moment des frappes il y
aurait eu des nationalistes ukrainiens
on sait pas exactement ce que ça veut
dire mais ici des responsables de la
police ukrainienne ont confirmé qu'il
n'y avait aucun militaire au moment où
ou le bâtiment et du coup les autres
bâtiments alentour ont été ont été
frappés et il affirme que cette frappe
de viser absolument pas des cibles
militaires